most of the intelligence community
doesn't believe he uses the ones that do
call him the Winter Soldier he's a ghost
you'll never find him
they join shield to protect people got
to build a better world sometimes means
tearing the old one down that makes
enemies
fast
Malhar
are you ready all it takes is one step
people are gonna die
again that that happened
Captain America needs my help
when do we start we just did
prices freed inside
and it's a price I'm willing to pay
he told me not to trust anyone
this is how it happens everything goes
looks like you giving the orders now
captain damn right
how do we know the good guys from the
bad guys if they're shooting at you
they're bad
hey youtubers its charlie happy
Superbowl Sunday
so Marvel just posted the new trailer
for Captain America there are a bunch of
new scenes mostly playing up the origin
aspects of the Winter Soldier so let's
talk about that mostly careful for
spoilers if you don't know anything
about the Winter Soldier Marvel is kind
of already released the information on
the character already and he's a big
part of the comic books but in case you
don't know careful for spoilers so the
biggest part of this movie and the thing
that I'm most looking forward to after
watching this trailer is the Winter
Soldier origin story they're basically
playing him up is like an evil version
of Captain America even though it's not
quite the same in the comic books I
think they're going to imply that his
arm is made of the same alloy as Captain
America shield just so that they're just
as equally indestructible they're just
playing up the fact that these two
characters are gonna be an even match
for each other so it's not gonna be
physical force that resolves that
conflict as the title implies Winter
Soldier I think this is largely going to
be a redemption story for Bucky Barnes
obviously Robert Redford is the main
villain a lot of people think that he
might be Red Skull I have not seen any
evidence to that fact but it would be
really cool and it would be a very big
comic book twist and Marvel is a comic
book company we also saw some new
Anthony Mackie scenes I'm really looking
forward to seeing his suit in execution
also side tangent if you have not been
watching agents of shield this is a
shield movie so obviously that's going
to integrate just a little bit the
season finale of shield is also going to
air within a week of this hitting
screens so I'm hoping that the finale
kind of ties in with the plot Chris
Evans isn't gonna go on the show
obviously but hopefully Coulson will be
mentioned or at least has some sort of
brief cameo in the movie there were a
few confusing moments in the trailer
when they were standing above that dead
body it's kind of meant to imply that
that's Nick Fury because we've seen Nick
Fury get attacked and be in the hospital
he obviously probably does not die in
this movie because Samuel Jackson has
several more movies on his Marvel
contract so he's not gonna die in other
news I am doing at least two more movie
trailers tonight I'll be doing Days of
Future Passed and transformers for those
trailers we'll be airing later today so
look for those videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything right now
click here to get my latest arrow Q&A
and you can
here to get those other Super Bowl
trailers I'll add the annotation as soon
as I post thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives